that was one of the best days of my life
honestly like signing day just knew that
all the hard work that i put into this
dream finally paid off i'm noble i'm a
freshman at brown university i'm a
receiver on the football team became
apparent to me that uh when i got to
high school
if i wanted to achieve the goals of
going to division one
going to school in the ivy league
that i needed to improve on my sat
scores a lot of people like my peers
have test anxiety first time i took it i
got a 12-10 i knew i needed to improve
if i wanted to get to the level of
school that i had envisioned so i dug
into the khan academy a lot i took
advantage of the option to upload your
sat scores to khan academy and it would
give you feedback on things you needed
to work on i definitely took a lot of
stress off of my shoulders and like
having the confidence that i could truly
go into this test and perform to the
standards that i wanted by using khan
academy i was able to improve my sat
score by 210 points i was able to get a
14 20. and that was the score that got
me accepted into brown definitely would
say it's life-changing i set my life on
a trajectory that wouldn't have been
available if i didn't have access to
khan academy whether you're upper class
or lower class or anywhere you fall in
between those
free and available for everyone and
that's i can't stress that's the amount
i want to leave a message that anything
is possible i definitely think the best
beginning spot would be through khan
academy